welcome back to baseball with uncensored
well from the formation of wan to his
untimely death george michael was an
enigma as well as a gigantic talent but
one person who knew the real george was
his former longtime partner kenny goss i
speak to kenny in just a moment for his
first television interview in five years
but first there's a new final work i
guess it is it's a documentary about
george michael's life it claims to give
an insight into his very public career
and his tumultuous private life let's
take a look at a clip
you have a right to walk away the music
industry takes away that right from
every artist it signs george had raised
the bar to a whole new level it was a
revolutionary thing and i want to leave
songs i believe i can leave songs that
will mean something to other generations
george michael who was without a doubt
one of the most talented
singer-songwriters this country in fact
the world has ever seen
and his death was obviously tragically
early and
we all miss george no one i guess
probably more than my next guest who's
kenny goss who spent 15 years
with george kenny it's great to talk to
you
hey how are you we don't really know
each other but i knew george quite well
and had some great times with him uh
seems like i know you from from
uh
weren't you in the showbiz editor or
something like that years ago when you
were when you were i'm a lot older than
you but
it must have been 20 years maybe yeah
you've aged better seems like i know you
uh yeah i used to do i actually ran
around some of the papers but i used to
i used to see quite a lot of george you
ran the sun for a while in the news the
world no yes and also the daily mirror
yeah
yeah but i have something i i'm not
doing
a mirror well i was gonna say about
about my
dealings with george was he was always
incredibly candid you know i can
remember some dinner parties where he
was just you know outrageously funny but
very revealing um i did some interviews
with him he was the same he was a kind
of heart on the sleeve kind of guy and
i'm just curious this documentary film
it has a lot of people talking about him
it doesn't have you
and i always felt that of everybody
around george's life you would have
known him probably as well as anyone
i would definitely say
uh
he would say that as well absolutely
uh what you're very correct about is
george uh was one of the most honest
people i've ever met and sometimes uh he
almost used honesty
uh as a weapon not and i mean weapon in
i'm gonna tell you this i need to tell
you this uh i've done something you need
to know uh and uh
uh so you always got the truth from him
absolutely
by the way the documentary that you are
talking about the one that you and i did
correct no i'm actually talking about
the new one which is coming out now with
all the big stars in it uh you're
talking about the simon napier bell film
right okay you know i don't know a lot
about that one right i do know about it
but uh i haven't really watched it uh i
think i know what it says
uh
uh but but i i wish it luck
i mean i think the the point that people
have made about it is it's a it's a bit
of a
not a whitewash of his life but it may
not be as
real as it should be and that the
reality of george's life was that
towards the end of his life certainly
the last decade or so he was on a pretty
downward spiral into
you know a very difficult
kind of lifestyle uh he was pretty
honest about it to me that even when he
was with you and you've been very candid
about this as well you know it was a
kind of open relationship
from his point of view he had lots of
i think from he was probably and i'm not
saying anything i would say he uh
probably was more open than me uh but uh
i loved him very much he knew that
the public perception of george is what
it is i'm having trouble hearing him
guys can y'all oh can you hear me can i
appear this
that well this air thing keeps cooling
out i apologize uh all right don't worry
i'm sorry i'm missing your i'm messing
your whole show up and i'm not at all we
get this is it live tv don't worry about
it i just wanted to ask you uh can you
hear me
you can hear me okay
i can hear you now yes yeah i just
wanted to ask you what do you think the
biggest misconception about george was
that the public may have had
um
i think the thing that
i always try to remind myself of and
this really wasn't a misconception i
think most people knew this was i don't
think he ever thought he had a good
looking moment in his life
uh
uh i always tried to remind him or tell
him you know you look really good today
uh you're a handsome man uh it was very
difficult for him uh
and uh
and it seems so i think to many people i
know that's well known but i think to
many people
they would think he would have a much
higher
sense of hey i'm a good-looking guy
and you know that i'm sure but uh
that's something i'll never forget one
of the first times that we've probably
been together two weeks
and he uh or maybe three he came home
and he said
uh darling what's good looking about me
and i said that's why are you asking me
that and he said he told me he said
someone said you were better looking
than me
and uh i said uh
darling uh
what was the quo and i asked him the
question again because i really had
never had a guy ask me that question
and uh i said
there were so many things i should have
said but i said your lips
and uh
now if it had been a girl or anybody
that had more time i'd have said
everything's good looking about you
don't you get it i'm i mean you know he
was
you know
always voted most handsome in the world
all these different things and uh
but what he did know
uh was that he was a talented man and a
good songwriter i mean he was he was
without a doubt i mean he was one of the
greatest the greatest talents i think
musically this country and the world has
seen certainly in my lifetime
i think um
that's the thing that always amazed me
um
uh
i am probably the most unmusical person
that he could have ever gotten with uh
he always said i had the same five cds
in my cars when we met and uh
i can honestly tell you
um
i can't remember the words
to the songs you wrote about me and it's
uh it's a shame i've since he's been
passed away i've actually started
reading the lyrics
and uh actually i started doing that
before he passed away and he said oh my
god
he said i liked you better when you
weren't reading them because you know i
would ask him almost childlike questions
like like
i this room you say that i'm in uh where
is this room
and and this chair he'd say darling it's
symbolism
and i and i said okay i said but uh
are we going to see each other
i said you're an atheist
you know questions like that that were
very childlike but but it made me think
and i did understand what symbolism was
but i said i'm always an angel in all
the songs
and i said are you my angel
and i said you called me a drunken angel
darling
i said i said i said you know if you
know how angels work they don't go they
don't drunken angels don't get many
assignments
you know i mean kenny you hadn't you had
you had 15 you had 15 years with george
and it was a great love affair well that
was all you said that because uh it was
15 years yeah and um
uh and he said something once and it and
it was i said darling why did you say we
weren't together two and a half years
and
and you know he had already started
kind of you know not being necessarily
as president
as
we'd gotten used to as he had been and
his answer was just simply uh darling i
don't know i just did it
and um
and i said okay uh how are you
uh yeah
and towards the end is it right to say
that i mean would you have been worried
about the state that george was in with
all the drugs i was worried about him
all the time yeah yes yes i mean but
please don't
say that the wrong way it's it's if you
love someone you're worried about them
you know it's
uh
that time when i said that you know
flushes drugs down the toilet that's
just because i was worried about it
i'm so cautious now uh about everything
i say and it's
you know it's a tough way to live
uh
because
you know i mean i you know i was quite
pleased for
uh 14 years being long suffering
you know i didn't really like uh because
my if you google my name it often says
long-suffering partner kenny goff a
long-suffering texan and uh uh and uh
but you know
i really did try to be always be there
for him and he knew that you know um
he
he i'm
i know he chose me to please his mother
i mean he told me that you know um
he had this
view that his my mother his mother and i
was very much alike and in a lot of ways
we were i would say i'm probably
uh not probably i'm much more uh
a guy that
plays by rules
uh and she was kind of the same way i
mean i'm also not judgmental at all
but uh
you know
uh
if you if a speed is a certain uh
you're supposed to drive at this speed i
drive at that speed if you're supposed
to you know and he really played by his
own rules kenny when you heard when you
heard that really
when you heard that he died at such a
horribly young age
obviously you would have been massively
shocked but what were your emotions
about it all given that you'd split up
from him but you'd stay closer um
i would stay uh close uh
um but i you know
we'd all expected him to die
uh
uh
i had spent so much time uh
when we lived together uh
being worried about it
uh
um
uh and
honestly uh you know he
hated the fact that i worried about him
so much uh
he
what's the line he says in the song he
says um
i could see it in your eye when you
looked at me that way
it tears me in two
and uh
it really did uh
i just didn't know what to
do and kenny what's up
really close friend when you when you
look back on your relationship all your
time with george
what's your favorite memory
if i could relive a moment you have with
him uh
um
there's so many that uh
and what i what i always do notice is
that
that there was a lot longer time that i
was incredibly happy with him than i was
wearing with him
like i might watch an interview with you
and go wow he looks good then
or parkinson and
and he was and he always said such
wonderfully kind things about me
uh it's
and that you know that's makes me feel
good because you know
he he always said
that i saved his life
uh i think that's you know a bit
uh much but uh
i really did try and he often got upset
with me because i don't think i ever
called him and didn't say
darling please
uh
a lot of people love you
yeah
i don't think he ever knew just how much
he was loved he was an amazing character
i love george i thought he was
fantastically entertaining brilliantly
talented english people forgave him for
everything we did we did they did i mean
it's it was you know you know why
literally he had a fantastically british
sense of humor and he got him out of
every scraper
it's great to talk to you uh i've always
wanted to have a chat with you i love
you it sure is uh uh i i wish i had more
time to talk to you i just want to say
he was one of the most wonderful men in
the world yeah uh
and uh i want people to remember that
i'm so glad that our true
honest documentary's out yeah it's such
a relief well i think there'll be a lot
of talk about george and a lot of uh
stuff about both these films that have
come out but i appreciate you joining me
tonight kenny and uh you know it'll be
good to actually remember what a genius
he was apart from everything else all
the best
yeah thank you have a great day thank
you bye
george michael what a talent he was
you